lors de la dernière campagne électorale
l'environnement était sur toutes les
lèvres des milliers canadien crier haut
et fort quel point ils étaient
préoccupés par les changements
climatiques
pourtant l'hiver n'ont fait élire que
trois députés
on avait 500 mille personnes dans la rue
avec greta table et on n'a pas pu gagner
un seul sèche au québec le débit de
monein est l'un des huit candidats qui
tente de succéder à isabelle mais c'est
un ancien libéral qui croit que le parti
vert a besoin d'une bonne dose de
pragmatisme
il va investir massivement dans
l'électrification des transports
mais en même temps il propose un retour
à l'équilibré budgétaire d'ici dix ans
évitez de des idées flyé comme probable
c'est pas un problème on va juste à
trouver de l'argent
ça n'a aucun bon sens comme lui l'ancien
ministre de l'environnement de l'ontario
guembri pense que le prochain chef a
besoin d'être terre à terre il partit
mieux organisé il ya beaucoup de
problèmes avec la dernière élection avec
l'éducation qu'à peine pour faire cela
face à ces candidats se disent
pragmatique d'autres croient que le
parti vert de se camper très à gauche va
ce qu'on appelle l'écho socialiste par
exemple meriem haddad et dimitri la sq
harris deux avocats de montréal veulent
éliminer la pauvreté en taxant les plus
riches
ils s'engagent aussi à interdire toute
nouvelle construction d'infrastructures
pétrolières pour tous les travailleurs
du pétrole parti vert du canada à leurs
offres d emplois fédéraux garantit les
gens ils veulent pas une défense du
statu quo ils veulent une programme
audacieux
oui mais certains candidats s'inquiètent
de voir le parti tourner trop à gauche
l'activiste torontoise un ami paul crois
que les verts doivent être ambitieux en
matière d'environnement et de justice
sociale tout en évitant un virage
radical
les membres aux anciens ne cherche pas
une à énorme à ré direction à
apport à notre parti pour la politologue
geneviève tellier le parti vert est à la
croisée des chemins
moi si j'étais vert mon but dans la vie
moyen terme ce serait de remplacer le
npd est donc mon objectif de remplacer
de devenir la gauche canadienne
cette gauche canadienne là elle est
verte ce serait ça mon but ce noël le
parti a une occasion de prendre plus de
place au parlement de devenir la voix
des canadiens préoccupé par le climat
conditions dit elle de ne pas trop
flirté avec les extrêmes la personne qui
va être choisi vont nous dire beaucoup
de choses sur la suite des choses pour
le parti perd ici laurence partie radio
canada ottawa